[Musique]
séjour de barbecue au csld paul emile
léger et one grave sel sucre et alcool
les résidents se permettent quelques
écarts c'est très agréable de faire
autre chose que des normes
habituellement des chiens gerber n'en
déplaise au menu deux barrettes ses
menus instaurée par l'ancien ministre de
la santé à partir de 2016 visait à
augmenter la qualité et la variété des
plats offerts en ch sld
on avait un menu équilibré peut-être
trop ou très équilibré pour eux ils
voulaient qu'on l'aurait réintroduisent
des charcuteries donc on a remis le
jambon le bon vieux jambon à l'ananas
est de retour mais c'est cependant une
exception dans cette cuisine laboratoire
on travaille à remplacer la viande comme
dans cette quiche lorraine sans jambon
ça c'est la grande tendance on essaie
vraiment de ramener les usagers les
patients à manger plus en plus
végétarien plus de protéines végétales
et - d'origine animale ici on refuse de
dire que l'on achète moins de viande
pour économiser salle un effet
dramatique sur la planète on est dans
l'urgence un peu on veut pas changer les
habitudes matin faut s'adapter pour
changer ni à réduire la quantité de
viande qu'on consomme finie la pizza
toute garnie mon pépé roni bar on a
voulu être écrivain elle dresse avec le
goût des végétariens et ce sont les
légumes ou les fromages le fromage mais
ici on a une pratique s'appelle
protéines végétales texturé autre
nouveauté la boulette de hamburgers sans
boeuf même la célèbre tour tiers en
maintenant sa version végétarienne ce
que je goûte l'heure c'est la tourtière
s'en vient c'est sans viande
avec quoi dedans lanthier champignons
tofu oignons et épices importées la
traditionnelle
sans ces écouteurs s'accroît très bon
les nouveaux menus végétariens ou pas
sont évalués par des comités d'usagers
de l'établissement montréalais ici en
milieu hospitalier centre sud de
montréal
on a une très forte clientèle en
croissance végétarienne et vegan donc on
nous l'avons là tous les jours non de
gallas mais plusieurs résidents de ch et
celle des voltes aussi réduire leur
consommation de viande
je donne une petite poche de manger
végétarien puis vous avez beau sont pas
toutes ces histoires manenti ce thème
comment j'ai la gamme mais qui en
mangent pas qu on leur payait dont
personne ici ne veut parler d'une
révolution végétarienne on préfère le
terme évolution qui n'écartera pas le
simple plaisir de manger
[Musique]